[Music]
hello and welcome to Adam and James play
video games here on PlayStation grenade
I can't believe this we are playing
Parappa the rapper 20 years after I
first played it here on the ps4 Jimmy
Mac have you ever played Parappa the
rapper before I haven't I never played
the original I haven't tried this demo
yet but I understand from what you've
told me this is quite an influential
game for its time it was yes it was a
trendsetter for all of us of music
genres rhythm games things like that it
set the pace which it then failed at
itself but 20 years later let's see if
we can relive my memories and let's see
if you want any rhythm at all I look
forward to reliving your memory Adam and
James baby be okay video games hey yo
games I don't little James my video
games yes it's all in the mind what am i
missing something now no no right ready
on the top he'll go first that's him oh
that's him him oh okay I get it now I
was pressing it every single time oh my
god you suck me hunt well done well done
you gave meh summer right after you've
done it perfectly press it a few times
after words from our points okay
rhythmic quick
oh so do you play my rhythm get to the
limit in order to get better now kick
butt yes he's getting it come on so what
I didn't get before is that that first
go-around with him and I'm duplicating
what he's doing so I was trying to do
his bit and being like ha ha and get it
now I can see by your not talking a lot
that you concentrate yeah quite a lot
I'm the worst person in the world to
come to you for a game like this [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah that's a sub that solid James
is playing now which means you can't
sleep no cuz he can't do two things at
once I don't stop talking over me Oh
terrible move it oh oh yeah it's getting
better keep going Jim off the massive
score of 53 right
they're yummy okay so 50 points oh wow
does looks terrible what means on my god
i can go insane it should still be able
to win this let's see what a master can
do pressures on I'm gonna go insane so
let's say why oh you can do that you can
are you could cut it over and over again
on the beach you feel a bit silly a
little bit yeah and you here at my
school you can just go yeah one but I'll
go insane yeah I feel a bit embarrassed
now of a bit nice car just a little I'm
gonna turn the sound up in just look
away i'm doing alright i can get 300 you
want every one game but but to be fair
this is what 15 20 years of practice
gets here slight bit of rhythm and a
little bit hrithik yeah its natural
music
oh yes amazon oh no it don't work so you
can't technically just found the button
there must be some sort of real rhythm
to this that you have to keep them I say
okay but I'm still gonna go insane with
music do this so once you've got those
first three in order so you have to
continue doing them in order yes okay
not only factors city differently then I
didn't what happened so i'm not sure
going say now 314 boy Jimmy Mac I am the
master yeah I can't know that I really
feel genuinely embarrassed now Jimmy Mac
would you like another girl I think I
would yes please so Jimmy Mackey's
having another girl he got 59 points
first time around I got 314 he's having
one last girl to see we can live up to
the master days Adam I'm so scared
there's no excuses this time that's a
good start hey oh yes he's getting it
kkkkkk cake pop off a punch oh oh you've
got more points after one go I'm ahead
of a nine points up your hope you're
gonna win you're gonna win what can I do
to put you off I think when it gets the
three button combos you're gonna go to
pieces I'm trying to feel better yeah
yeah I'm not even listening to you right
now
oh this is gonna be close if you can do
three bar bollocks you like the gareth
gates of the rapping scheme I don't know
exactly not a lot of stuttering o turnin
pause nah he's duck duck turn right not
to pressure you but you you're
absolutely smashing my school and I
really so you just got a bit to do three
button combination oh no no no no I
don't wanna do for fun of lectures good
I know awesome that was awesome oh you
haven't failed anything yet oh it's
mixed one up is messed up no I thought
of thing oh it's mess to up always
bringing it back she's gonna be so close
oh I think I won this I think I know oh
kool Shen it was just those two stages
you had that one all the way through
apart from that one little glitch or
accepted who I'm actually sweating a
little me I'm gonna beat me i was i was
talking to big earlier i feel like i can
at least be slightly less embarrassed
now like and subscribe and support our
tiny channel take a look at this video
on the left won't take a look at this
video on the right oh just enjoy our
logo in the middle
you